Lonely Planet presents: How to Survive Small Talk.
Small talk should be small.
Keep your topics light and your pace brisk.
Have engaging answers ready for generic questions.
For example, "How's work?" should be a springboard for a delightful anecdote.
A simple, "Work's good." simply won't suffice.
Monosyllabic responses didn't serve you well as a teenager,...
...and it certainly won't stand as an adult.
Unless you already know the answer to a question, don't ask it.
"How's your boyfriend?" might seem like a great opener...
...until you realize he ran off with the pool boy.
"Catch me up!" or "What's new?" are less likely to lead you to a conversational cul-de-sac.
Lastly,  you can master all this and become a small talk superstar,...
...but you can't make people talk to you.
If you get no response, cut your losses and head to the bar.